my
notes uh suggest in which a conspiracy
hypothesis
is accepted by the mainstream with no
acknowledgement that that is what
has happened and yes this was published
uh
in the new york in new york magazine
on why is there no date fasting oh
january 4th 2021
so yeah in within the last week january
4th so roughly a lifetime ago
by nicholson baker called the lovely
hypothesis yes and it's quite
good um i mean maybe zach should put it
up yeah i think he
should i send him a link to its act you
want to it's also on my screen if you
want to show it there
okay um so this
article is very very well written and
it covers a lot of the people that i
hold in high esteem who have been
both courageous in discussing the lab
leak hypothesis
including yuri dagan who was on the dark
horse podcast
um and some others who i've become aware
of who
have bucked the academic trend and
talked about
this and what it does is it takes the
lab league hypothesis
and it legitimizes it so that now
anybody
can discuss it and the reason that this
is so
important is that we have this
period between which it was obvious that
there was something to discuss
and the mainstream has effectively been
forced to admit that
and that period is going to be lost to
history i have a feeling but its
significance
is uh hard to overstate and i mean i am
flabbergasted that this is a point that
needs to be made but when you say there
is a period during which
uh between which it was obvious that
there was something to be discussed and
now
it's entered the mainstream and so we're
sort of allowed to discuss it and this
is a period that lasted
well more than half a year um
because we we began talking about on
this podcast in april
of 2020 um what you said
is exactly right but this nuance which
is not really nuanced will be missed by
some people
it is obvious that there was something
to be discussed what you have said
is not it is obvious that it is true
this is in fact your distinction
between theory and hypothesis right that
the idea
that it is a possibility that we should
be considering on the table as opposed
to we've got an idea that is true
it's that this is a you know this there
is a an
animal in the market in wuhan and that's
what that's the origin of this virus
that is the only thing we're allowed to
consider at the point back in april may
june etc of last year
that you had scientists no less
credentialed
scientists working as scientists earning
their pay as scientists
who said there was one and only one
possible explanation for where this
virus came from
and for you to think anything else is
irresponsible that
right there is anti-scientific because
what scientists do is they observe
something
and they say what are all the possible
explanations for this thing
and lab leak was obviously a possibility
from the very beginning and by saying it
was obviously a possibility is not
saying it was obviously true
saying it was obviously a possibility so
it was obviously a possibility
and interestingly um you can
see it was captured in my twitter feed
exactly how early it was obvious that it
was a possibility and so
the percentage likelihood that it was
the explanation for for the pandemic has
changed for
for me and presumably for everybody uh
checking in with that idea
but zach do you want to show the um
screenshot
of my twitter feed from february
4th screenshot of my twitter feed from
february 4th seems
really specific let's just set the stage
here for a second heather
you and i were in the amazon this is
february 4th 2020.
february it was like less than a week
after we got back from ecuador
i think i was hoping you'd know the
exact date off hand maybe you don't
butch
but
that we left the amazon the date at
which we went from being completely
without communication
in the in yasuni in ecuador
to returning i mean cell phone reception
again becomes possible at the military
checkpoint
um when you are transitioning
back to the town affectionately known as
coca
that's going to have been january 24th
january 24th
okay and then we came back to the cut to
the u.s on january 28th
um so
the fact of the corona virus
what was then called novel coronavirus
was unknown
to us while we were in the amazon we
emerged and
at uh while we were in eau de vallo um
in the andes
in the andes uh decompressing and
getting ready to return home
literally decompressing giving the lower
air pressure up there
wow so yes we were decompressing in the
andes
looking at hummingbirds and all sorts of
other stuff but
uh in any case we emerged from the
amazon the world had begun to grapple
with the idea of a novel coronavirus and
you know
if you think back to where you as a
listener were
to the novel coronavirus at that point
you know there have been a number of
these
um emergent viruses you know
sars and mers and uh bird flu and things
like this and
um you know so there's always this
question about oh no there's this virus
that's been spotted what's going to
happen is it going to take over the
world is it going to burn itself out
and so it's very hard to tell at the
point that we caught wind
of the novel coronavirus how bad it was
going to be
there was a nature paper and is that
what you're referencing here and what's
on screen here yes it was a nature paper
that
outlined the um the wet market
hypothesis and the fact
that it had been uh that the virus had
come from bats
and i thought as a bat researcher i
thought it made sense for me to look at
this paper
i'm always a little bit troubled when um
[Music]
diseases are associated with bats
because people don't know how to
calibrate it there's so many species of
bats and yes bats do vector a lot of
diseases because they fly and therefore
they're good vectors
but you know people don't understand you
know
the little brown bat in your backyard if
you're listening to this in the united
states is not vectoring
these diseases right it's not likely to
and it's not likely to carry rabies
either though that's a possibility
but unlikely unlikely but um in any case
the the fact is the viruses are the
enemy of the bats too so in some sense
we're on the same side and i i don't
like to see bats demonize but anyway i
thought i would look at the paper i
would read it it said you know
uh batborn coronavirus wuhan
uh seafood market and i just thought i
would weigh in and say
i've looked at it it makes sense to me
and i did
and that was at 10 30 in the morning
of february 4th and
i immediately got pushback from
followers who said oh so it's just a
coincidence that there's a bio
uh safety level four laboratory studying
bad coronaviruses in wuhan where the
drivers
emerged right the fact about which you
were previously unaware
completely sure and i thought
that's a hell of a coincidence there's
probably something about the story i
don't know at least i need to understand
why that coincidence is not
stunning right that piece of information
puts this hypothesis on the table as
something that obviously needs to be
considered
obviously needs to be considered and as
yuri
dagan pointed out when i talked to him
and as i
thought one of the things you need to
know you know i wasn't really
deeply thinking about what a bio safety
level 4
laboratory was and i had no idea how
many of them there were
you know if there were a thousand such
laboratories and the fact that there's
one in
wuhan may not be significant it's just a
coincidence
you know if there's one and it happens
to be in wuhan it's a spectacular
coincidence and it happens
there are a handful but that one of the
two
primary ones studying coronavir batborn
coronaviruses
in wuhan is certainly a stunning fact
and many many of us
who are on the heterodox side of this
question
have had this exact same experience
which is as soon as you realize that
wuhan
is the location of such a lab that it
was studying exactly these viruses
and it is the first place that humanity
becomes aware of this virus you know
that there
if you're an honest broker you know that
there's something that has to be
considered
yeah so this um this paper this
article this magazine article that's out
this week in the new york magazine
uh cites a piece from 2012
uh is published in the bulletin of
atomic scientists
which i would love to read just the
first two paragraphs from because it's
directly relevant sure so 2000
um sure if you want to it's on my screen
it's called the unacceptable risks of a
man-made pandemic
by lynn klotz and edward sylvester for
those of you looking i don't know why
the first paragraph is partially
replicated so i'm reading the first two
paragraphs even though it looks like i
just skipped one
now that world attention finally has
been focused on the potentially human
contagious h5n1 asian bird flu virus
remember this is written in 2012.
the international research community
should take steps to deal with three
other potential pandemic pathogens
two are among history's nightmares
smallpox which killed or made millions
of people over centuries that ravaged
the world and the resurrected 1918
pandemic flu virus
which may have killed 50 million people
worldwide over just two years
the third is severe acute respiratory
syndrome or sars a newcomer that proved
how lethal it could be in one natural
outbreak during 2002 and 2003
when it killed 9.6 percent of those it
infected a fatality rate almost four
times higher than the 1918 flus
these potential pandemic pathogens or
ppps
pose a danger that goes well beyond the
potential of other hazardous microbes
that have made the news
the ppps are all extremely deadly highly
contagious or potentially highly
contagious in humans
and not currently present in human
populations meaning it would be a
disaster to reintroduce them into the
population
of the three smallpox researched at only
two facilities in the world by
international agreement
poses the smallest threat of laboratory
escape at russia's vector and the u.s
centers for disease control
lab workers have been vaccinated to
prevent infections to themselves it
might spread to others outside the lab
in stark contrast to the strict controls
on smallpox research however
sars the 1918 flu virus and potentially
human contagious h5n1 bird flu
are studied in laboratories throughout
the world using less than the highest
biocontainment known as biosafety level
4
or bsl4 and there is no approved and
stockpiled vaccine for
any of them so
yes the there is awareness of the
hazard which in fact resulted in an
intense effort to study bad corona
viruses um and there's also been a
competing awareness of the danger of
studying them and
in particular of studying using
techniques called gain of function
research where
viruses are enhanced to see what they
will be like when they become
truly infectious uh which and the
hypothesis the lab leak hypothesis
i think for all of us who have tracked
it carefully is not
there is a version of it in which the
virus simply ends up in a laboratory
and unmodified escapes from the
laboratory into the world that's a very
unlikely to be true
because the virus that would have ended
up in that laboratory would not have
been highly transmissible between people
and if there's one thing you can say
about sars kovi 2 it's that it is highly
transmissible between
humans right it's a trick it's very very
good at and so the question is where did
that happen
and while possible the idea of this
virus happened to be in a lab it was
unmodified
is less parsimonious than this virus was
out in in the wild
and transmitted without having an
intermediate step in a lab
right well there one would expect an
evolutionary
period in which the virus either picked
up a skill
through recombination with some other
virus so time to evolve without human
artificial selection
right so you there's a number of things
you would expect and we have evidence
for exactly none of them right it
doesn't have a long period of time in
which it learned to go from person to
person
it doesn't have you know many people
have hypothesized things like pangolins
and other
intermediaries but there's no evidence
that this actually
occurred so anyway there's a there's a
whole lot of mystery but what i wanted
to point out about these screenshots is
that they actually happen to document
a thought process and give it a time
stamp so
february 4th 10 30 i
tweet i have looked at the nature paper
cited here and the evidence
that the novel coronavirus came from
bats possibly rhinolophus of finnis
uh or another species sorry it's at a
distance that's hard for me to read or
another species that shares roots with
it
is fairly compelling how it jumped to
humans is less clear
but wet markets are likely okay that was
10
30. by my next tweet which was
11 29 i said several followers have
pointed
to a competing hypothesis and the nature
paper does not allow us to distinguish
between the two
the virus likely comes from bats that
much is true
the bushmeat trade is dangerous also
true those things may well be unrelated
in this case now my reference to
the bushmeat trade is obliquely about
hiv which the best explanation for how
hiv ended up in humans
is um basically chimp
butchery that resulted in the virus
transmitting to a human
so in any case
that's less than an hour by one minute
right
the between your two but between my two
tweets
the fact of the uh bsl4
lab in wuhan is sufficient to raise the
skepticism
of an honest broker thinking in a
scientific
mode it didn't mean that it was the
probable answer there
now the irony is as the lab leak
hypothesis has
been defended by courageous people
willing to take the risk of being
dismissed as conspiracy theorists or
trump loyalists or whatever it is that
the accusations have been
um as that hypothesis has you know
clawed its way into uh
grudging acknowledgement by the
mainstream that it is something
that reasonable people might consider
the explanations
that were offered as official have
fallen
right everybody including china
acknowledges the wet market had nothing
to do with it there weren't bats for
sale there
so the point is the other hypotheses
have crumbled even as this one has
gained steam
right now a person could have
a wild conspiracy theorist that is to
say somebody who
is not exerting any sort of analytical
discipline could have landed on the
right answer here
and they would turn out to have been i
won't say right because we still don't
know that the lab leak is what happened
but would turn out to be in this
credible position almost by accident
right a person who was methodical and
careful and just simply following the
logic and the evidence where
it led would have ended up here too so
you can't really distinguish those two
things
but over time one of these hypotheses
has gained ground because it is
impossible to refute so far
and the circumstantial evidence is very
strong there's no direct evidence but
the circumstantial evidence is
incredibly strong
as we iteratively fail to falsify a
hypothesis
it looks ever more likely to be an
accurate representation of underlying
reality
right and what's more if it turns out
lab leak is not the explanation
all of the things that we will have
learned in the attempt to falsify
that hypothesis are now basically a
description of what a better hypothesis
would have to explain
in order to take the lead right and so
people will remember back in
would have been june or july uh
i said that one of the ways to deal with
this stuff responsibly
is to uh rank to give a percentage
chance that you think some possibility
if you have competing hypotheses what
you think the percentage chance is and i
made a little flow chart
and i went through all of the things
that i could think of that could
possibly explain
where this virus had come from and i
ranked lab leak as very high
something like that i think this was far
earlier i think this was may frankly
may have been anyway may have been may
but in any case there's a way to do this
and there's a way to do it responsibly
and the amazing thing is when you do it
responsibly even when you have
you know a credential that uh means
that somebody has agreed that you have
this the
toolkit with which to do such a thing
even then you face these amazing
appalling accusations
of being a conspiracy theorist
right um being irresponsible spreading
uh
false information um you know i mean
even uh
peter dashik who it turns out was
central to the funding pipeline that
resulted in the money that
allowed this coronavirus to be or these
coronaviruses to be studied in the wuhan
lab this guy with this incredible
conflict of interest right
he was leveling accusations of
conspiracy theorists against anybody
including us
for for talking about this stuff so
the point here is two things and as
usual you know follow the actual
conflict
it's easy to accuse people of having you
know having secret
financial connections and some people
presumably do
or being grifters or whatever but when
there's a known conflict of interest
by someone who is accusing other people
of
spreading information for which there is
no support but you can actually point to
the support or the failure to falsify
well then the conflict of interest
speaks really loudly
yes the conflict of interest um uh is
deafening at some
level and in peter dashik's case it's
just amazing
how far he has gone to uh
ridicule and erode the credibility of
anybody who even raised
this possibility um in public
but um so this comes up here for two
reasons
one this is the week in which this
hypothesis has become mainstream and
suddenly
you should expect a very different level
of conversation about it because
effectively people have been signaled
that it is now safe to acknowledge the
obvious
right safe to acknowledge the obvious
now how many topics
do we face this kind of situation why
is it ever unsafe to acknowledge the
obvious ever gosh i just have this image
of someone like
peering out from a storm cellar door is
it safe to acknowledge the obvious
right is it safe to acknowledge the
obvious is it is it safe
you know to acknowledge that men and
women are different phenomena
you know well we'll get back to you
right not all that's safe at the moment
maybe we'll get there
um but the question really and
the interesting thing this is just
happenstance that this arises in the
same week
as the uh insurrection at the capitol
and if need be i will defend that word
um
in a moment here but the insurrection at
the capitol and what may be much more
important which is the downstream
uh at least narrative consequences so
things have been moving incredibly fast
in the last
day and ostensibly that is the result
of the uh the invasion of the capitol
building
some of it can't possibly be i i
frankly didn't have enough time uh in
becoming aware
of the fact of a new anti-terrorism bill
that is ostensibly the result of
uh responsive to the events of the
capital um
you know i wasn't able to look at it but
this can't possibly be
uh responsive it has to have been uh
ready to go in large measure and then
you know some giant many many many page
bill that was
that someone is arguing was created in
response to what happened on wednesday
uh
i don't i don't know anything about this
well the number i've seen was something
like 20 000 pages now that could just be
rumor i'd like somebody to validate that
i went looking for it and
time ran out uh on me uh before the live
stream but nonetheless yes
there does appear to have been a lot of
stuff ready to go
and then the events of the capital seem
to have created pretext
for it to be unleashed and
um what i so what i want our uh
listeners to do is to keep
what has happened with the lab leak
hypothesis
and then what has you know the latest
chapter is it has gone mainstream i want
them to keep that in mind
as they try to grapple with what is
taking place
ostensibly as a result of an egregious
breach at the capitol building
you